Silvester kommt
59% der Deutschen sind für ein
generelles Verbot von privatem Feuerwerk
ich eigentlich auch über 2000 Tonnen
Feinstaub wöllern wir jedes Jahr in den
Himmel Haustiere drehen durch im
Altersheim denken alle der Russe kommt
andererseits feuerwerk zum Jahreswechsel
soll böse Geister vertreiben und ich
muss sagen da ist was dran die deutschen
Böllern seit Jahren immer weniger und
alles wird immer beschissener cor
Wirtschaftskrise die Bahn wir können
kein Fußball mehr spielen da gibt es
doch offensichtlich einen Zusammenhang
probieren wir es doch ausnahmsweise mal
mit merböllern nächstes Jahr wird in
Thüringen gewählt und die AFD steht bei
34% sorry aber es hilft nichts auf ein
etwas weniger bekacktes neues
Jahr